bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
alors la banque centrale européenne va
donc augmenter 1 son plan de rachat de
dette pour soutenir l'économie de la
zone euro l'enveloppé initiale de 750
milliards d'euros va être abondée de 600
milliards d'euros est ce une bonne
nouvelle ou bones audition tout
simplement
non pas du tout parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que cet argent là c'est de
l'argent qui est créé de façon explose
c'est par un simple clic d'ordinateur
voilà et donc c'est de l'argent qui
correspond pas à des biens qui ont été
produits donc ça quand on regarde
l'histoire économique et monétaire on se
rend compte que ça se traduit un jour au
l'autre en inflation alors on pourrait
me rétorquer que jusqu'ici malgré les
curieux que la banque centrale
européenne fait depuis des années il ya
peu d'inflation c'est pas tout à fait
exact n'y a pas d'inflation sur les
biens de consommation mais il ya de
l'inflation sur les actifs comme
l'immobilier ou les actions dont il ya
quand même de l'inflation ce qu'on
appelle de la façon d'actifs mais là
avec ces plans qui qui passe à un niveau
supérieur complètement délirant depuis
la crise du corps d'un virus on reste
vraiment d'avoir de l'inflation aussi
sur les biens de consommation et sa
sauce un catastrophique parce que ça ça
rogne aurait sérieusement le pouvoir
d'achat des européens et donc ça ne
ferait que prolonger la crise
donc concrètement on pourrait le
ressentir en fait les ménages en france
ou en europe pourraient leur faute ce r
oui tout à fait et s'il ya six un
décollage de l'inflation ça se traduira
par une baisse du pouvoir d'achat ça se
traduira par les incertitudes aussi pour
les entreprises parce que quand les prix
se met à déraper les entreprises c'est
plus compliqué pour prévoir les oilers
investissements donc sur un effet très
négatif
et puis l'autre effet négatif évidemment
c'est que les taux d'intérêt se remet
très remonté parce que les investisseurs
qui achètent des bons du trésor français
ou italien si l'inflation est à 5% à 7%
à 8% ils vont demander des taux
d'intérêt qui soit au moins du même
niveau et mais avec des taux d'intérêt
de ce niveau là à payer le budget de la
france il explose le budget de l'italie
il explose en vol complètement et donc
ça mettra en grande difficulté les états
qui sont très lourdement endettés comme
la france l'italie l'espagne
voilà c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent et ce n'est pas le
cas de la banque centrale européenne et
je trouve que c'est une erreur voilà
surtout que à quoi ça sert ses affaires
du déficit budgétaire mme des plans de
relance je suis pas convaincu que ce
soit ça qui permette de relancer
l'économie européenne justement la
banque centrale européenne a décidé de
maintenir son taux d'intérêt à zéro les
banques elles se verront appliquer un
prélèvement de 0 5% sur les dépôts est
ce que cette politique monétaire est
adapté aux circonstances actuelles de
l'europe
non parce que les taux zéro c'est
quelque chose qui n'avait jamais été vu
depuis
depuis que la monnaie existe en fait le
un tel niveau de taux zéro depuis autant
d'années et même de taux négatifs
ça ne s'était jamais vu dans l'histoire
monétaire c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement
nouveau extrêmement négatif parce que ça
décourage départ il ya des épargnants
aujourd'hui ça ne rapporte plus rien ce
que l'assurance vie se comptaient
livrets bancaires en france ou en
allemagne où ça leur rapporte plus rien
et donc on décourage les parcs ce qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui est très mauvais voilà
donc c'est pas du tout une solution les
taux zéro et puis des taux zéro il faut
aussi comprendre que ça affaiblit les
banques parce que le métier des banques
c'est de récupérer de l'argent auprès
des gens quand on donc des épargnants de
les rémunérer avec un peu taux d'intérêt
et de prêter cet argent un taux
d'intérêt plus élevés à ceux qui ont
besoin les entreprises ou les
particuliers qui veulent emprunter pour
acheter leur logement et la banque se
rémunère sur le dip sur la différence
entre le taux d'intérêt auquel elle
prête et celui auquel elle rémunère
c'est la marge d'intérêt est le problème
si cette marge d'intérêt aujourd'hui
elle est proche de zéro à cause des taux
d'intérêt nuls et donc ça a fait des
secteurs bancaire ce qui est une très
mauvaise chose parce que si on après la
crise économique que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui si on a une crise bancaire
là ça va vraiment devenir très compliqué
à gérer
la présidente de la bce 1 christine
lagarde table sur un recul du pib de la
zone euro compris entre 8 et 12% cette
année vous êtes d'accord avec ces
estimations
j'ai pas des moyens de vérifier mais
c'est un ordre de grandeur qui va être
celui là et qui va être extrêmement
sévère 6-2 lors des 10 % c'est à dire
s'est il faut comprendre que c'est le
c'est trois fois le niveau de la crise
de 2008
donc ça va être extrêmement sévère sur
sur l'économie il ya encore une fois je
pense pas que ce serait que des plans de
relance qu'on peut sentir et moi je
considère qu'il faut plutôt baisser les
impôts favoriser l'offre et diminuer les
normes et la bureaucratie ça c'est
spécialement pour le cadre de la france
c'est plutôt comme ça qu'il faut
encourager la création de richesse
plutôt que d'augmenter les dépenses
étatiques qui vont servir à ceux qui
seront les capter bon on donne 7
milliards d'euros à air france alors si
une entreprise qu'elle est déjà assez
mal avant la crise
quel intérêt pour avoir 6 7 milliards je
me pose la question
voilà et à côté de ça il ya plein
d'indépendants de commerce qui vont
fermer parce qu'ils sont ils auront le
couteau sous la gorge
voilà donc c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut
redresser l'économie
merci beaucoup philippe berling d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste